en tout cas c'est le seul et unique
hôtel de la saucisse au monde 78 euros
par nuit pour une chambre simple 81,18
pour un lit double au cas où on a envie
de faire la fête
bien évidemment et on il est également
possible de suivre un cours de cuisine
et d'acheter de la charcuterie la
caroline en mai il était temps vous
iriez vous en week end à l'hôtel de la
saucisse franchement valérie quelques
bonne saucisse parents de temps en temps
des si de là ça n'a jamais fait de mal
pour la santé la sas et patrimoine
culturel chez eux est un symbole pour le
pays
il était temps que vient à peine de la
saucisse comme bien des tonnes très bien
jamie je vous vois lever les yeux au
ciel on n'irait pas la tête de
l'associer à dire que le dr murray del
associés
[Rires]
total de la merde je vais informer c'est
ça c'est triste pour l'ami dont je fais
partie mais j'avais donné vous comptez
aussi la boulette
vous en pensez de l'amiante et c'est
vrai que la saucisse en allemagne est
une institution c'est vraiment le plat
national pour vous donner un exemple
quand j'étais en classe de quatrième en
allemagne
en fait avec berck en quatrième mais
exactement dans le cadre d'un échange
franco-allemand et j'étais avec mon
correspondant est systématiquement lors
de la courte dans la cour de récréation
se mettait dans un coin on avale et
chacun une saucisse sont bas plutôt
manger des sucreries de jean dauger
voilà pour la récréation en allemagne ce
sera plutôt des soucis du sésime tolosa
villette on parle de l'avc entre un père
le docteur oui et elle associe ces
politiques en allemagne c'est à dire
qu'en france par exemple lorsque des
responsables helvétiques s'affiche avec
un verre de vin ouais en allemagne par
exemple
angela merkel elle va croquer dans la
saucisse alors il ya une façon de
croquer dans la saucisse c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'angela merkel par
exemple un moment donné ont jugé qu'elle
croque un peu de façon trop agressive
dans la zone verte c'est la presse
commente la façon dont directement on
commente la façon dont vous parce que ça
donne une idée sur les clauses 1 parce
que c'est un objet phallique et
l'associé donc si vous croquez trop fort
dans la saucisse à un moment donné ça va
donner une mauvaise image de vous pour
vous attendez vous allez nous montrer
comment on croque bien dans
l'association est ce qu on a des
socialistes on pourrait faire venir
[Applaudissements]
damien bonne liste c'était le gros si
vous avez bien venir
j'ai l'impression que caro et tenter
d'en parler avec moi non mais qu'on a
presque au mans où la façon dont les
politiques allemands s'emparent de la
saucisse si j'ose dire oui tout est en
l'occurrence un gala merkel elle a une
façon trop carnassière exactement
d'ailleurs pas nous donner un exemple
l'ancien chancelier allemand à sao
regarde chaudhary là le fond on dit en
allemagne avait des rumeurs comme quoi
il avait pris des cours pour manger la
saucisse pour pas paraître et
d'insouciance aussi c'est aussi ces
victimes etc alors en traîneau ça se
passe de façon élégante évidemment on se
sait jamais de l'amour de l'art de
manger une saucisse et qu'il aimerait
attention au filet de bave et surtout
manger là vous cher mais c'est un très
grand moment de télé quoiqu'il elle
habiterait bien voilà le problème c'est
qu'elle est absolument immonde pas on a
bon voilà on s'attendait pas ce que
j'allais froide aussi j'étais
impressionné bien merci
[Applaudissements]
je ne portais pas premier rang du
scolaire sur l'autel de la c6 mèneront
jusqu'à la politique allemande
et là franchement je dis chapeau damien
vous avez bossé votre sujet pour la ces
des vacances à l'hôtel de la saucisse je
pourrais y aller comme caroline ou bien
c'est n'importe quoi pas menaçante quoi
à 70% des âmes errantes % à avoir envie
de tenter le coup 1 un petit week-end
festif va l'autel de la saucisse en tout
cas dans cet hôtel il accueille aussi
les chiens et évidemment il leur donne
quoi à manger des saucisses
à kayes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]